>> WE ARE LOOKING AT MAYBE 6 TO
8 WEEKS BEFORE WE HIT PEAK AND
START TO COME DOWN BUT WE
BELIEVE IF PEOPLE ISOLATE AND
STAY IN GROUPS OF UNDER 10, WE
BELIEVE PEOPLE AVOID
NONESSENTIAL TRAVEL, WE BELIEVE
IF PEOPLE STAY HOME FROM WORK OR
TELEWORK THAT THOSE ARE
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO GOT VIRUS.
WE ARE LOOKING AT SOUTH KOREA
AND ITALY AND SCIENTISTS FEEL
VERY COMFORTABLE THAT THE
MITIGATION EFFORTS WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT BUT THEY REQUIRE
COOPERATION, 50 TO 70% OF THE
COUNTRY REALLY COOPERATING AND
DOING THEIR PART AND THAT’S
WHAT’S MOST IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW.
STEVE: YOU HAVE THE SURGEON
GENERAL ON THIS PROGRAM 90
MINUTES AGO TALKING ABOUT
ISOLATING, SOMEONE WHO KNOWS
WHAT EXACTLY THAT IS LIKE SOUTH
CAROLINA SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
HE’S OUT OF HIS SELF-ISOLATION.
HE GOT THE TEST.
IT WAS NEGATIVE.
SENATOR, FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
WATCHING AND WORRIED ABOUT THIS
SELF-ISOLATION THAT THEY ARE
GOING THROUGH RIGHT NOW BY NOT
BEING, YOU KNOW, CLOSE TO OTHER
PEOPLE, WHAT ADVICE DO YOU HAVE
FOR THEM BECAUSE IT’S SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THAT?
>> WELL, WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH HERE?
AMERICA IS UNDER ATTACK BY A
VIRUS.
HOW DO YOU KILL THE VIRUS, DENY
HUMAN CONTACT.
THE BATTLE PLAN IS NO SOCIAL
GATHERINGS, NO EATING OUT, NO
SCHOOL, NO SPORTS, STAYING
BASICALLY HUNKERED DOWN IN
PLACE, REDUCE WORK OPPORTUNITY,
LIVING OFF LESS INCOME, THAT’S
HOW IT WOULD KILL THE VIRUS.
UNLIKE 911 WHERE 1% HAD BEEN
FIGHTING THE TERRORIST, 100% ARE
FOOT SOLDIERS IN THIS BATTLE.
IF YOU’RE OUT OF WORK, CONGRESS
WILL TRY TO GIVE YOU A PAYCHECK.
THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION NEVER ENVISIONED
ALL THE SMALL BUSINESSES NEEDING
LOANS, SO THIS PACKAGE WE ARE
WORKING ON CALLED PHASE 3 IS
DESIGNED IN MY VIEW TO GIVE
PEOPLE INCOME TO GET THROUGH
THIS.
AINSLEY: SENATOR, SOME PEOPLE
DON’T UNDERSTAND WHAT IS GOING
ON IN WASHINGTON, WE HEARD PHASE
1, PHASE 2, AND NOW PHASE 3,
WOULD YOU TELL US WHAT’S GOING
TO HAPPEN, WHO WILL BENEFIT FROM
ALL OF THIS?
>> IF YOU’RE OUT OF WORK YOU
NEED PAY.
HERE IS WHAT I’M WORKING ON WITH
DEMOCRATS AND IN SOUTH CAROLINA
YOU CAN APPLY FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE, MAXIMUM PAYMENT IS
$623, NOT NEARLY ENOUGH TO GET
THROUGH THIS.
YOU MAY BE HUNKERED DOWN 6 WEEKS
OR LONGER.
I’M WILLING TO PAY 75% OF
PEOPLE’S INCOME UP TO $80,000 TO
GET US THROUGH THAT.
THIS OUGHT TO BE ENOUGH MONEY TO
GET US NEXT 6 TO 8 WEEKS.
BRIAN: SENATOR, YOU TO RAISE THE
THRESHOLD A LITTLE BIT.
COUPLES THAT ARE 150 AND SINGLES
75, IF YOU MAKE $150,000, YOU
TAKE HOME ABOUT 90.
YOU HAVE 3 KIDS, I BELIEVE THAT
THEY HAVE TO BE ADDRESSED TOO.
THE MIDDLE-CLASS MATTERS.
>> BEFORE THE VIRUS YOU HAD AN
INCOME, RIGHT?
IF YOU WEREN’T WORKING YOUR OWN
UNEMPLOYMENT, WELFARE, AFTER THE
VIRUS, YOU’RE NOT WORKING.
I WANT TO RESTORE YOUR INCOME.
I DON’T WANT TO GIVE YOU A
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND SAY GOOD
LUCK, I WANT AN INCOME STREAM,
EITHER COMES FROM EMPLOYER,
WILLING TO LEND -- LET EVERY
EMPLOYER BORROW MONEY TO MAKE
PAYROLL AS LONG AS THEY DO
PAYROLL AND I’M WILLING TO
INCREASE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
CAN YOU GET MOST OF YOUR CHECK.
STEVE: SENATOR GRAHAM, WHAT IS
GOING ON IN WASHINGTON IT’S
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVEN’T
ACTUALLY SEEN HAPPEN MUCH OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS AND
THAT IS YOU’RE TALKING TO
DEMOCRATS, DEMOCRATS ARE TALKING
TO REPUBLICANS, STUFF IS GETTING
DONE.
>> YEAH.
STEVE: THIS IS WHAT EVERYBODY IN
AMERICA NEEDS YOU TO DO RIGHT
NOW AND IT LOOKS LIKE YOU’RE --
YOU KNOW, CONGRESS IS RISING TO
THE OCCASION.
>> YEAH, THE IMPEACHMENT DEBACLE
HAS BEEN REPLACED BY THE SPIRIT
OF 911.
I THINK AMERICA IS UNDER ATTACK,
IT’S UNDER ATTACK BY A VIRUS
THAT CAN BE DESTROYED IF WE STAY
AWAY FROM EACH OTHER.  VIRUS
NEEDS HUMAN CONTACT TO SURVIVE.
ALL OF THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
STAYING OUT OF SCHOOL, NOT GOING
OUT TO EAT IS GOING TO KILL THE
VIRUS OVER TIME, BUT REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS HAVE ONE MISSION
IN PHASE 3 IN MY VIEW, IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU GET MOST OF
YOUR INCOME, IF NOT ALL OF IT,
MOST OF IT AND HOW DO YOU DO
THAT, YOU DO IT THROUGH LOANS,
BUSINESSES, YOU CAN DO IT
THROUGH UNEMPLOYMENT SYSTEM, BUT
WE HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER LIKE
PEOPLE ARE AT HOME.
BRIAN: SENATOR, I HAVE TO ASK
YOU, STORY IN WASHINGTON POST
THAT JARED KUSHNER IS RUNNING A
PARALLEL RELIEF PLAN WITH THE
VICE PRESIDENT, THEY ARE ON
SEPARATE TRACKS AND WORKING
AGAINST EACH OTHER, NOT ON THE
SAME PAGE, YOU TALK TO THE
PRESIDENT AS MUCH AS ANYONE.
IS THIS, IN FACT, TRUE?
>> IT WOULD BE NEWS TO ME.
THIS IS A WARTIME PRESIDENT.
I TALKED TO HIM LAST NIGHT.
HE IS GOING TO TRY TO COME UP
WITH A BATTLE PLAN TO KILL THE
VIRUS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AND
HELP THE ECONOMY STABILIZE UNTIL
WE GET THROUGH THIS.
I HAVEN’T SEEN ANY IN-FIGHTING
PERSONALLY.
YOU CAN KILL THE VIRUS IF YOU
STAY AWAY FROM EACH OTHER.
BRIAN: IS IT ACCEPTABLE FOR THEM
TO BE WORKING ON DIFFERENT
PATHS?
>> ST UNACCEPTABLE FOR US TO BE
WORKING IN DIFFERENT PATHS.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS, WHAT
DO YOU HAVE, CONSTITUENTS OUT OF
WORK, WHAT DO YOU DO WITH PEOPLE
THAT HAVE LOST WORK IN MYRTLE
BEACH, AINSLEY, YOU GIVE THEM A
PAYCHECK.
YOU CAN FORGIVE THE LOAN LATER.
ALL ABOUT SHOULD BE ABOUT INCOME
STABILITY.
YOU JUST LOST YOUR JOB, I WILL
DO EVERYTHING I CAN TO MAKE SURE
IN THE NEXT 48 HOURS OR 72 HOURS
YOU FIND A WAY TO REPLACE YOUR
INCOME.
BRIAN: YOU KNOW WHAT THE
PRESIDENT’S MESSAGE AT
11:00 O’CLOCK TODAY?
>> 3 THINGS TO LOOK FOR.
THE DAY WE HAVE FEWER CASES,
THAT’S TURNING THE CORNER.
REDUCE MORTALITY, THAT’S TURNING
THE CORNER.
WHEN A VOCZONE IS ON THE
HORIZON, THAT WILL BE TURNING
THE CORNER.
I THINK AT 11:00 O’CLOCK YOU
WILL HEAR OPTIMISTIC NEWS ABOUT
THERAPIES AND TREATMENTS TO SAVE
PEOPLE’S LIVES, BUT UNTIL THEN,
FOLLOW THE BATTLE PLAN.
STAY AT HOME.
STEVE: YOU DID STAY AT HOME WHEN
YOU WERE SELF-ISOLATING AND YOU
RAN INTO SOMEBODY IN MAR-A-LAGO.
FOR THE PEOPLE ISOLATING, DO YOU
KNOW HOW TO PASS THE TIME
BECAUSE IT’S DRIVING PEOPLE
CRAZY?
>> YES, I WATCHED THE CROWN, I
WATCHED THE VIETNAM WAR.
I STAYED ON THE PHONE.
WE GET TO KNOW EACH OTHER
WHETHER WE LIKE IT OR NOT.
COMPARE THIS TO WORLD WAR II.
WE HAD BLACKOUTS, WE MAD MOST OF
OUR SONS AND DAUGHTERS GOING TO
FOREIGN LANDS TO GET KILLED.
THIS IS NOT THAT KIND OF
COMMITMENT.
IT IS A SERIOUS MOMENT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY TO DEFEAT THE
VIRUS.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS STAY AT
HOME AND MAKE SURE THAT IF YOU
GET SICK, YOU’RE RESPONSIBLE
ABOUT IT.
STEVE: THAT IS SO WELL PUT.